otro hospital ucraniano reducido a
escombros por los misiles rusos lo que
constituye un crimen de guerra los
habitantes de venecia siguen
conmocionados tras los múltiples
bombardeos de las fuerzas del kremlin
sobre las posiciones civiles
no puedo creer que haya sobrevivido el
tranvía me salvó cuando hubo una
explosión yo estaba en esa plaza oí un
ruido y vio un punto lo único que pude
hacer fue cruzar la calle
los equipos de rescate continúan
buscando supervivientes decenas de
personas resultaron heridas y al menos
23 han muerto incluyendo cuatro menores
entre los fallecidos lista una niña de
tan solo cuatro años con síndrome de
dawn la tía de la menor habló de su
dolor
no entiendo por qué hay tanto odio hacia
nosotros no hemos hecho nada a nadie
nunca atacamos vivimos pacíficamente y
trabajamos los ucranianos somos gente
muy trabajadora nos gusta trabajar nunca
amenazamos a nadie entonces porque rusia
nos ha hecho esto simplemente no puedo
explicarlo
y
por su parte el presidente de volodymyr
selenski pidió reconocer a rusia como un
estado terrorista y reiteró su promesa
de llevar ante la justicia a todos los
responsables del mortífero ataque
tras la venta en venecia y otros ataques
terroristas del ejército ruso los
ocupantes deben sentir lo que significa
una respuesta justa al terror en
particular se sentirá gracias a las
sanciones
algunos vecinos realizaron el viernes un
altar improvisado a las víctimas
mientras que rusia asegura que el ataque
iba dirigido a un edificio donde las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas se reunían
con proveedores de armas extranjeros
kiev niega por su parte esta versión